hi my name is Dan mace and yesterday the
21st of March 2020 I tested positive for
the covert 19 virus in Cape Town South
Africa I'd like to sit here today and
share my story my symptoms and insights
I have gained for the purpose of
scientific research and in hope to help
save lives firstly this is the letter
that you get after you going for the
swab test are either two SARS
coronavirus two RNA was detected in the
sample and then I got a call from my
doctor to say that I've tested positive
but I get started these are some basic
simple facts about myself in hope to
better understand for research purposes
one I am 30 years old to my diets at the
time of contracting the virus is vegan 3
I'm reasonably active for I do take
medication daily it's an SSRI pole for
depression it's called sytrus and the
doses 10 milligrams 5 I have no
allergies 6 I've had no previous
life-threatening illnesses and lastly
this video may be repurposed
I'm not going to mana ties this video
and I won't put out any copyrights as my
sole purpose for this video is to help
better the research ok the story begins
about a month ago it was on the morning
of the 19th of February in my apartment
in Los Angeles I woke up with extreme
fatigue I couldn't understand why but
every single time I tried to get out of
bed I just as soon as I stood up I just
felt completely faint and I went to lie
back down I then later got in touch with
my business partner to tell him that I
won't be able to work that day I still
couldn't understand exactly what was
going on and what I had said to him was
that it was probably just a whole bunch
of stress then I proceeded to sleep that
entire day and woke up that night with
extreme night sweats my bed unlike
were both drenched then the headache
that came on the morning after was
alarming the pain the sensation of my
eyes super super sensitive to the light
and this overwhelming sensation of
dizziness as well as just feeling really
lightheaded
but that morning I then opted to try and
get outdoors as I took advice from a
friend of mine which was you know that
I'm probably just going through the
motions of extreme stress from work and
maybe by getting outdoors and doing some
exercise it would reduce this so I got
into the car and off we went to go and
surf but it was by the time then when I
put on my wetsuit I realized that I was
so out of breath It was as if I ran a
marathon without actually doing any
exercise I didn't try to paddle out into
the lineup but after failing to do so I
realized that whatever I was feeling was
just not caused from stress as I had
never experienced anything like this
before
that night again the 20th of February I
woke up with intense night sweats
possibly worse than the night before I
took to my computer and I wrote in all
the symptoms that I was feeling but
nothing yet came up about the corona
virus the only symptoms released then
were that you would have muscle pain and
croaky throat but however I was highly
panicky and really knew that something
was not right that night I couldn't
really sleep and I did a whole bunch of
research really trying to figure out
what's wrong with me what I hadn't yet
realized is I'd completely lost my sense
of smell and taste I just hadn't had an
appetite in those three days so I wasn't
yet Willey aware of it on the morning of
day 4 February the 23rd I woke up and my
heart was racing my heart was really it
was beating so hard in my chest my head
was spinning my eyes were super
sensitive to light and my ears were
highly sensitive to sound I had a huge
pain in my chest but still no red nose
and no phlegm in my chest but I did have
a strangely dry cough and I just knew
that it was time to see a doctor
immediately I didn't try to stand up but
I couldn't
so my business partner arranged for a
doctor to come and visit me in my home
in Los Angeles
well waiting for the started to arrive I
decided to get into the phone with
another doctor's a family friend of ours
who just asked me a couple of questions
like have I been to China recently and
when I said no he said this absolutely
no ways that I can have the virus I then
explained all the symptoms from my
headaches to my fatigue to muscle cramps
to my cuff to the night sweats and he
assured me that it was just a local flu
then when the next doctor arrived I was
really seeking answers so you know I
asked him please can I get this corona
test there's people on the news speaking
about this illness that's going around
and he said to me have you been to China
recently and I said no then he asked me
about my symptoms he checked my vitals
and said that I just do not show enough
extreme symptoms to go through the
process of having a corona test but what
he can do is give me an influenza B test
which is a similar test to the corona
virus test the kovat 19 test which is a
white tube with a bat on the top that
they put up your nose and take a swab
put it out and they can do the reading
right then and there which came up
positive for an influenza B which he
then told me this may turn into
pneumonia and then gave me a list of
symptoms which I could possibly feel
within the next couple of days which are
very very similar to those what would
have uncovered themselves as now as the
kovat 19 symptoms he then gave me a flu
shot told me the rest and to not do any
exercise for you know the next five days
I then once again asked him are you sure
that I do not have this corona virus and
he looked at me and said you definitely
do not have the virus it's just a normal
flu that 35,000 people in Los Angeles
have had already this year the following
two to three days things started to get
we were son I developed what I believed
then to be pneumonia it took a large
amount of energy just to get a deep
breath of it and I've never felt
anything more intense and that sensation
in my entire life
at the time I was having this internal
debate with myself because I had seen a
medical professional and spoken to
another that it assured me that
everything was going to be okay now that
I look back that I was really
downplaying these symptoms and then
finally on March 1st 2020 I woke up and
I started feeling oddly normal I made
myself a cup of coffee i sat down on my
desk and I started working like I would
have any other day and then it was when
I made myself breakfast that I realized
if I had absolutely no taste and no
smile and that I hadn't had these two
senses since the day that I became ill
and then since I had been assured and
reassured by doctors that I don't have
any Korona symptoms and I was feeling
better I just returned to life as normal
making videos being active I celebrated
my 30th birthday on the 7th of March
with friends we went snowboarding and
surfing in the same day doing activities
and I felt completely normal and
present' on the 10th of March 20 2004 in
an Emirates flight from Los Angeles from
LAX that flew its way to Dubai and for
Dubai to Cape Town my reason for doing
this trip was to celebrate my wedding in
South Africa the following week now what
super important to note here is on
landing in Cape Town they screened every
single passenger that was on board
I got screened it's a little temperature
dial that they put up against Jafar yet
they read your temperature and if you
show symptoms they make you stay if not
they let you pass they screened me and
they let me pass I then went home I saw
my family I saw my parents I went on a
weekend away with really close friends
of mine to my bachelors where we were
all in very close proximity together we
then attended a big music festival in
Cape Town on the Sunday
but on the Monday I still hadn't got my
sense of taste or smell back then it
wasn't Tuesday the 17th of March where
other patients that have tested positive
for the clover 19 virus came out saying
that they have no sense of taste or
smell this all of a sudden immediately
urged me to go and get tested now in
South Africa we are really fortunate to
have an incredible testing facility it's
super simple to get tested you just have
to get a note from your doctor you go
down to the path care facility you hand
in your document and they give you a
swab and it takes about two to three
days for you to get your results and
that takes us to the 21st of March 2020
the day that I was supposed to get
married
we're obviously our wedding was
postponed and for the best reasons
possible been on that afternoon my
doctor phoned me and told me that I have
tested positive and I got these folks
now I have absolutely no idea what this
all means I have not shown any symptoms
since being ill in the states other than
of course the loss of taste and smell
which is really [ __ ] by the way did I
indeed get the virus when I was in the
States if so I just truly hoped that I
was passed and fix the stage by the time
I got on a plane and decided to fly back
to South Africa but there were eighteen
days between the time that I was feeling
ill and recovered and got into the plane
to get on to South African soil there
are just so many unanswered questions
right now and I'm in no way a medical
professional I'm just hoping that my
story can somehow help others out there
and in the meantime I am in isolation in
my house in Cape Town for the next 14
days with Gabby and with Joey come say
hi
just go say that about Joey hello guys
we are sending you all love and I'll
keep you posted with my symptoms moving
forwards but you know like I said
hopefully it's all in the past
I am isolated in my house and will do my
best to make creative videos while I'm
sitting here I'm sure that it's gonna
drive me insane 14 days well other than
that don't forget your awesome brew and
stay safe
[Music]